hi everyone welcome to this webinar on
the foundations of causal inference and
its impacts on machine learning
my name is emrakujiman i'm a senior
principal researcher at microsoft
research in redmond
and i'll be speaking to you today
together with amit sharma who's a
researcher at msr india we're both part
of a group of researchers at microsoft
interested in causal
inference and causal machine learning
and that
will be our topic today
uh in this webinar we're going to talk
about why causal inference is important
what we believe is
is special about it we'll walk you
through four steps of causal inference
and give you a detailed walk-through of
these steps with the do i python library
finally we're going to close with some
of the more fundamental connections
between causality
and what are core machine learning
challenges
so why is causal inference important
we're motivated and i'm certainly
motivated uh
by this uh trend of
computing uh being becoming more and
more integrated into so many parts of
our society
with data-driven decision-making really
transforming the way that
we make decisions in the context of
health and medicine
industry retail and many other scenarios
you know if i think about medical
scenarios like whether
an image of a skin lesion seems to be
cancerous if i think about what
how people's behaviors will change if i
raise the lower retail prices if i think
about
what are the implications of
agricultural decisions like what cover
crops to plant or when to
irrigate these are all questions that
are
are benefiting from this trend towards
more data-driven decision making
enabled by the advances in computing
that have been happening over the last
decades and when we think about how to
take that data and turn it into
into decisions we often think about
machine learning
and what machine learning is hard is
doing is searching for
patterns in this data and using it to
pull out insights that we can use to
gain a better handle over what decisions
we want to make and what will
help us in all these various domains
the problem is that often these uh
patterns that correlational machine
learning finds are spurious ones
the problem with machine learning
algorithms finding these spurious
patterns that these
is that these patterns are not robust
machine learning
fundamentally makes an assumption that
the data it sees in training is
representative
of the data that's being used uh
that where the test data where it's
being used
and deployed and when that assumption is
broken
machine learning makes mistakes so for
example algorithms that work really well
at reading handwriting
recognizing objects answering questions
about images
all start to fail when
when the data that they're being
deployed on changes and we see that
here where digits are being analyzed at
different angles where
stop signs are being looked at from
the the questions that are being asked
and answered trying to be answered
through a
through an image are slightly
are slightly tweaked from the type of
questions that were being asked
otherwise and this can lead to some
serious problems and bad decision making
for example important importantly
it can lead to biases and machine
learning models in in really critical
situations
and so um why is
why what what what happens why do we
really care about this in decision
making scenarios
well it turns out that that when we
start to use machine learning
uh algorithms for decision making
we're not only assuming that the
environment isn't going to change we're
at the same time
because of the decision we're taking the
action we're going to make we're
actually actively changing the
environment in a way that often breaks
those patterns
so for example think about a simple task
of
learning a machine learning model that
will help us make irrigation decisions
in a farm
let's say we're going to be learning a
model to predict soil moisture levels
based on you know current readings and
future weather patterns
we can train these models on years of
sensor data from real farms
and then ask the question hey here's the
status of my farm right now and i know
it's going to be hot in a couple days
do i need to water my fields to make
sure the soil is
is a moist enough the model trained on
years of data
is very likely to say no the soil
moisture will be high
when the temperature gets really high
don't worry about it
and why would why might this model do
this it doesn't
make sense to to me right if it's going
to be really hot that's going to dry out
dry out the soil well maybe this model
learned that in the past
soil high temperatures were associated
with
with high soil moisture levels because
the farmer
in the past always watered on those hot
days
and when we're coming about now and
asking what's going to happen that was a
pattern that the the machine learning
model picked up on
but it's a pattern that we're going to
break when we look at this result
and decide not to irrigate based on the
model's prediction
so if we look at this together
we're seeing computing helping with
decision making in a
broader set of scenarios and we see this
potential challenge
where uh where uh
conventional machine learning patterns
aren't up to the task of
making good helping us make good
decisions
the interventions that we make based on
these analyses are break the
correlations that these machine learning
algorithms depend on and
when we look into their internals for
insight we often find that
they don't actually necessarily
represent the
the models don't give us insight into
how we actually might want to act in the
first place
so for decision making we need something
a little different we need to find the
features that both cause the outcome
and we need to be able to estimate how
that outcome would change if the
features are changed
so one way to think about this is that
you know in supervised machine learning
we're assuming that the training data
is the is matches the test data and we
have great ways of of estimating
um and evaluating a prediction
model and making sure that we're right
under these assumptions
causal inference is really a different
task though in some ways it looks
uh like a similar setup here we're not
assuming the training data
is the same as the test data and instead
of trying to
to simply predict uh the the value what
we're actually trying to do is
uncover the underlying generative model
the the
the values of the causal mechanisms that
are are
creating our observed data now this is a
good time to
step back for a moment and ask what is
causation
now this is a tremendously philosophical
uh question we're going to take a bit of
a practical
definition just
just to be able to to move forward and
make progress on some of these important
problems
we're going to say that some action or
treatment or decision t
causes an outcome y that we care about
if and only if
changing that value of that feature t
leads to a change in y while everything
else is constant
now what that means is we're going to
have some real world
data where we actively take action
and change t and we're going to be
asking the we're going to say the t
causes the the the change in y
if y would have been different in some
counterfactual world where we did not
set t to that value and the causal
effect then
if there is a causal if there is a
causal relationship the causal effect
is going to be the magnitude by which
the outcome changes
every time t change t changes by a unit
so we're going to estimate this value
now this leads us to two really
interesting fundamental challenges one
is that
we never actually observe this counter
factual world we
get to see what we did but
if we're really serious about that
assumption that all other things being
equal
we never get to see the counterfactual
world where we did something different
so this leads us to the first challenge
for causal inference where
we can't directly calculate the causal
effect say
you know for ground truth validation we
have to always be estimating the
counterfactual
if we do one thing we have to see we
have to estimate what would have
happened otherwise
if we do the other thing we have to
estimate you know what would have
happened on the other hand
and this means uh that there are among
other things going to be
challenges in validating our methods
the the second interesting fundamental
challenge
is that the there are multiple causal
mechanisms that can be fit to any data
distribution that we actually observe
we're not going to go too much into
detail about about why this is or how
but just suffice it to to say that data
alone is not enough for causal inference
we need domain knowledge and assumptions
to disambiguate the potential mechanisms
that could be causing
the observations that we see so
so this is going to be two of the
challenges that we're going to be
talking about
as we go through as we go through this
presentation
so just to uh uh highlight here that
that not o uh that in the context of
these decision making tasks there are
a lot of of uh data science and science
scientific questions that are really at
hard causal questions when we're doing
an a b
experiment that's one way of answering a
causal question
if i change this algorithm will lead to
for example a higher success rate
in whatever optimization metric i'm
looking at if i'm thinking about
policy decisions i might want to think
about i might want to estimate the
impact of that policy change
once i've deployed a policy and i want
to know whether
in hindsight that policy helped or hurt
given everything that
else has happened since i deployed that
policy now that's a very interesting
counter factual question where i'm
combining
my knowledge of how the policy works
with my observations of
of the world that i've the extra
information that i've learned since
and there's fun problems in credit
attribution
are people buying things because of the
recommendation algorithm i just
deployed would they have bought anyway
whenever i see some outcome that i care
about
can i tell where that came from
so if i was to recap why we should be
carrying why we care about causal
inference
it's it comes down to the fact that
decision making
in all these important scenarios depends
on understanding the effects of
decisions and actions if we really want
to optimize
how we make decisions we need to be
thinking causally
the predictions from correlational
machine learning are insufficient
because
because of the fact that our decisions
and actions are changing the the
correlations that machine learning
depends on
causal inference addresses this
challenge directly
but does run into new uh challenges we
have to overcome
primarily we have to start bringing in
outside knowledge to augment our
our observed data we talk about these
being model assumptions that we have to
explicitly
augment and we need new methods for
validation and new methods for
estimating those counter factual
scenarios so that we can
really know that we're making progress
and trust our results
so in the second part of the talk we're
going to go through the four key steps
of causal inference
so the four key steps of causal
inference that we're going to go over
are first how we model our problem this
is going to be about creating a causal
graph that encodes the assumptions that
we're bringing in from our domain
knowledge and our knowledge about how
the world works
to augment the data that we're using the
second step is identification
here we're going to be taking those
assumptions that causal
graph and model and using it to
formulate what we need to estimate
the third step is to actually compute
the estimate given all the realities of
the data sets what's the best way to
trade off the bias and variance for
whatever task we're trying to to do
to get a causal estimate of what is the
impact of
doing one thing versus another on the
outcomes we care about
and the fourth step is to is to validate
our assumptions
and run a number of sensitivity analyses
to really see if we can refute this
estimate see if we can
come up with a reason not to trust it
and this comes back to those challenges
around
the the lack of ground truth validation
for many of our tasks
which means that we have to find new
ways of making sure that our
analyses are trustworthy to implement
these four steps we built
do y it's an open source python library
for causal inference
our motivation for do y was really
was really based on our experience
working with data scientists and others
uh on causal inference and we noticed
that
the most challenging parts of of the
causal inference process wasn't the
statistical estimation
but actually the initial encoding of
modeled assumption of of assumptions in
the form of a causal model and the last
step
of of uh validating and refuting
the results at the end these were two
new steps that were
are different from what we do in
conventional machine learning and so
this is where
uh we thought people could use more
assistance
and that's what do y does it makes it it
makes it really steps people through
these four steps in a way that
ensures that people are making a
transparent declaration of their
assumptions
and helps them evaluate those
assumptions and the results that they're
getting
at the end of the analysis as much as
theoretically as much as it's possible
so these four key steps are going to be
the framing that we use for
the rest of this part we'll start with
modeling our assumptions
modeling and capturing our assumptions
is about converting domain knowledge our
intuition and concrete knowledge about
how the
the world works how the particular
system we're analyzing works into a
formal model
that we can use to augment our data
so a good model is built around exposing
the key
causal relationships between the outcome
that we're analyzing and the
other variables that might influence it
including the actions that we're trying
to take
the assumptions are about how different
variables affect each other
and we usually encode this as a causal
graph
where each edge encodes a mechanism uh
you know a direct edge is a from one
node to another from a to b in this case
is a direct
cause where a the value of a influences
the value of
b the graph itself
now in total implies a number of
conditional statistical independences
for example in this case their a and c
are independent of each other and you
know d
is independent of a conditioned on b
you can read these statistical
independencies off the graph
using rules that are called deseparation
rules
we won't get into that but it's a
fascinating topic if you want to
dive deeper into it the key intuition
about these causal graphs is that the
assumptions themselves actually aren't
the edges
the assumptions are encoded by the
missing edges
and the direction of the edges the way
to think about this is
uh as follows if i draw an arrow for
between two nodes a
and b what that says is that when a
changes
b's value is gonna is gonna change
weighted in some way
but that weight could be zero so really
drawing an edge
from between two nodes isn't assuming
anything it assumes that there might be
a relationship
but if i remove that edge then i'm
setting that weight to zero
by definition and i'm saying that if i
no matter how i change a
without some path between a and b b's
value is not going to change
these relationships that we're encoding
this graph also
represent stable and independent
mechanisms that is if we have
a large causal graph that is
representing a
a bunch of different stuff in some
system or environment
we can expect that if we reach in and
change the system in some way
we change some of those arrows we can
assume that the rest of the system the
rest of the causal graph is not going to
be affected
the another key intuition is that the
graph
actually can't be learned from data
alone while we can look at the data
and learn something about what the shape
of the graph might look like
it turns it it it turns out that
the the same data can you can be
represented
by multiple graphs we can narrow it down
and get to some equivalence class but
we're not going to be able to to find
the right one
and that's why we need to encode this
our domain knowledge explicitly because
we can't just skip this step
and figure it out later and finally it's
important
to note that these graphs are a tool to
help us reason about a specific problem
we can write these graphs at different
layers of abstraction at a high level at
a very detailed level
we can capture major uh
major causal relationships or the most
minor ones
and what the right answer in the right
way to model
the these these cause relationships is
going to depend on
the questions that we're caring about uh
and basically the context of the
specific problem
here's an example graph just to just
dive a little bit
into the interpretation of these graphs
here we're looking at a graph that shows
some of the relationships between user
interest
user fatigue what people have done in
the past and then some
anonymous treatment here that we're
considering won't say what it is some
outcome variable
reading this we can read off
what we're doing in terms of what our
assumptions are in the underlying system
we see by the fact that there's no arrow
from
user fatigue to user interests
and there's no path that we can follow
along these directed edges
to go from user fatigue to user interest
that user fatigue does not affect user
interests
we can change the values of user fatigue
we can you know
maybe find ways of making sure our users
get
more sleep or get more rest walk away
from
the system we're building and you know
and
feel more relaxed and
we will not be affecting their user
their their interests
we see also that past clicks does not
directly outcome
uh passively so the history of what a
user has done does not directly
according to this graph affect the
outcome that we care about this y
it does however indirectly affect it
through
through its influence over whether or
not people see
the the treatment that we're studying
um and so on now when
we are thinking about going in and
changing this
the the value of this treatment feature
t note that in this example graph we see
that t is being influenced by quite a
few things
but when we talk about wanting to go in
and set t
or change t what we're really saying is
we're going to build a new system
where the treatment t is not influenced
by these other variables
it's it's just simply influenced by
whatever we decide to do
we're going to reach in and change t
potentially completely independent
of what's going on the rest of the
system so now this is actually a new
intervention graph
it's uh basically a a new system where
all edges that we're going to have been
removed
now this represents a new data
distribution we usually refer to this
distribution using
do of t so this this operator and the
causal effect
that we want to capture in our analyses
in causal inference is
the basically the distribution of y the
probability of y
given do of t given that we are are
um setting the value t to some
setting the feature t to some value
and now this leads directly to now the
identification
problem the identification step of
causal inference
here what we're going to do is we're
going to take that p of y
given do of t and
we're going to try and figure out how we
can calculate that value so
uh the challenge here is that our
observed data is generated by the graph
on the left
where t is being influenced by
everything else going on the system and
those things are also influencing the
the outcome that we're observing and
the we want to answer questions about
this intervention graph where t
is being set by us independently of
everything else and so now
the question is how do we represent
quantities from the right-hand graph
p of y given do of t using only the
statistical observations
that are in the data generated from the
left-hand graph now
there's a trivial example a solution to
this in the case of randomized
experiments
in randomized experiments the value of t
is being set with a coin flip
it is statistically independent of
everything else so there are no edges
from the rest of the system to t
in the first place this means that our
observed graph is the same as the
intervention graph
in a randomized experiment and what this
means is that the
probability of y given do of t is equal
to
the observed distribution of p of y
given t
and uh this leads us to kind of our
intuition for how one one approach to
to doing causal identification it's
going to be basically
can we generalize
generalize this insight about randomized
experiments by
taking our observed data and trying to
find ways to tweak it to simulate a
randomized experiment
so when treatment t is caused by other
features z
for example we'll call it the set set of
feature z
we're going to try and adjust for their
influence to simulate a randomized
experiment
now this approach is called the
adjustment formula and
the adjustment formula you can see on
the screen is basically
um is basically adjusting for the
all the observed values of these um
feature z that are influencing the the
treatment
now the feature z can't just be any set
of features they have to be
a what's called a valid adjustment set
in order for this formula to give us a
correct estimate of the causal effect of
changing t
on the value of y there's a couple of
different
valid adjustment sets one is all of the
parents of t
if you if you set z to be all the
then this formula will give you the
right answer
you can also identify a set of features
using what's called the backdoor
criterion
and the towards necessity criterion
and the
the key intuition we're not going to
define these algorithms but there are
algorithmic approaches to
identifying these features the key
intuition is that the
union of all features is not necessarily
a valid adjustment set you just can't go
and use all of your data
to to do this you will get uh incorrect
estimates
um and um you know i just want to point
out you know you might be thinking why
why don't we just always use the set of
all parents of t
why do we need more complicated ways to
to
identify valid adjustment sets well the
issue is that sometimes
these parent features even though we
know they exist they might be unobserved
in our data set
so we might we might know that they're
there that they're that they are
influencing the value of t
but for one reason or other we might not
have been able to measure them we might
not have captured them in our data set
which means that we have to find
alternate adjustment sets that don't
include those unobserved variables
in addition to adjustment sets there are
many other identification methods
there are uh identification methods that
rely solely on
uh the shape of the graphical uh of the
the causal graph
um these are in addition to adjustment
sets there's the front door criterion
there's randomizing
natural experiments and then there's
also other identification methods that
in addition to the causal graph
require some additional constraints or
assumptions about the shape of causal
relationships
or the um or the
uh or narrow down on the kind of causal
estimate that we're
that we're interested in identifying
these include instrumental variables
regression discontinuities and
difference differences and many of these
methods uh can be used through
uh are already in rre in do you
at this point i'm going to hand off the
presentation to amit sharma as i
mentioned earlier amit sharma
is a researcher at msr india he's a
co-developer
of the du y python library and he'll
step us through the rest of the
four steps of causal inference starting
from estimation
and into the final part of the
the talk on
on the connection between causal
analyses and
core problems in machine learning thanks
very much
thank you emre i'm amit sharma and i'm
excited to present this webinar let's
move
to the estimation section now emerge has
talked about the first two steps of
modeling and identification and once you
have the identified s demand
we would want to use the observed data
to compute the target probability
expression for common identification
strategies
using adjustment sets the estimation
really just boils down to conditional
probability estimation
so here for example i'm just showing you
that the do operator converts to
a probability distribution of y
conditioned on t
and w and of course this is assuming
that the
adjustment set is a valid adjustment set
in binary treatment case the thing
becomes even more simpler so if you want
to estimate the causal effect
it's simply a subtraction between the
conditional distribution at t equal to
one
and the conditional distribution at t
equal to zero
and so in all the estimation steps and
all the estimation methods that you may
find
the final goal is that we want to
estimate the conditional probability
and you want to keep the confounders
constant
how do we do that let's start with one
of the most simplest methods known
which is just matching so so imagine
that you have data
about health and and you have people who
were given a treatment
which meant they did cycle and then
there were other people who did not
cycle
and your goal is to find the effect of
cycling on their health
right so we have these different people
here what the simple matching method
says
is that let's just match people who have
the same baseline health and confounders
together
so you match children with each other
you match people with different
characteristics
which are shown by colors here and once
you do that you have effectively created
a set
where the confounders are the same
between each pair
and so therefore when you just compare
their outcomes
you are guaranteed to get the causal
effect
and so as i share here of course in
practice you won't have
exact matches there might be high
dimensional data and so typically we
have a distance metric
as defined here and we say that a
matching condition is that the distance
metric should be lower than
a certain value epsilon now this can
work really well
if you have a small number of
confounders for example the equation
here just
you have to subtract the outcomes for
each match but in practice
you will have many people who would not
be matched
they are shown in the bottom gray box
here so these are people for which we
are unable to match anyone and therefore
we have to exclude them
from the data and as you can see just
simple method actually shows the
challenges
of building a good estimator uh
especially in high dimensional data
if you think about it we removed all
these people because we could not match
them
and that just meant that we had a very
stringent matching criteria
and that means that our estimate will
not be reliable because we just have a
small matches
that we have to rely on on the other
hand if you think you can just relax the
matching criterion
and obtain many more matches now the
problem is your estimator is biased
because it's no longer capturing the do
operator that you wanted
it's just not being able to keep the
confounders constant
and in the real world things become even
more complicated because often
you might just have a small set of
people who have been given the treatment
in this case cycling and so what will
happen is that those few people won't be
matched
as much and it will lead to both high
variance and
high bias and so what has happened over
the past decade
is that people have realized that we
need better methods to navigate this
bias variance tradeoff
and i'll just talk about two examples of
recent machine learning methods
that have come up that can help us in
this estimation problem
so the question i want you all to think
about is
let's say you try to match a person or a
data point
and a good match does not exist is it
possible to just
create a synthetic match let me describe
what i mean by it let's say on the right
hand side you're seeing
a graph about people the orange people
are the people who are the treated
people and blue are the ones who did not
get treatment right
so if you just try the simple matching
strategy as the
vertical lines show uh you would find
that there's no one else
in the blue case who had an equal value
of the confounder
to the person that i'm pointing to using
the vertical arrow
in the orange bar and similarly for
people who are in control
if you just pick one point at random and
see which person has the same confounder
you would not find anybody
and so what machine learning can help us
do is we can
actually estimate the function of the
outcome
for different treatment values so that's
what we do here
so we say let's take all the people who
are treated and try to find the
relationship of
w the confounders with y and in this
case
it's a straight line and we can do the
same thing
for the control group as well what does
this give us this gives us now
a pretty good matching for any person in
treatment or control
so for example for the blue bar here
instead of matching to a real person
i can just match to the prediction that
our model gives
and again we have to always make sure
that the function that we are estimating
is a good function approximator because
the key assumption here
is that the f that we estimate now
captures the true relationship between
the confounders and outcome
if that is true then the causal effect
again can be given by simply sort of
different differencing the outcomes of
the treated and the control
while they are matched with the same
confounder
and as you can see other machine
learning methods can generalize
estimation
to harder problems as well i'll give an
example of continuous treatments
so this has been a hard problem in
causal influence for many years
where it's pretty easy to do if you have
treatment equal to one and treatment
equal to zero
binary but what do you do when your
treatment can be continuous
so this is one method that has been
recently proposed which takes the cue
that
of course as we discussed earlier just
having a predictor is not enough so you
can't just take all your data
take treatment you take confounders and
just say i'm going to build a predictive
model
that's not the right approach but
there's a simple trick that you can use
to still be able to use predictive
models so what we do
is that we break down our task into two
sub
tasks let's look at the graph first we
can always come back to the equations
so what the graph is showing is that
typically why
the outcome is having some correlation
with the confounder and that's where you
see
a tilted line there and some of the
treatment can also have some correlation
and this is the issue we want to remove
this correlation so that we can actually
capture the effect of t
and y so what the double ml method says
is that let's build a predictor using w
and try to predict y and similarly let's
build a predictor using w
and try to predict t once we do that
what's nice is that whatever is the
residual left it's
literally the amount of variation in y
that is not explained by w
and so it is the unconfounded variation
that we want to look for
in y and so that's what this method does
in the first step
we take the gray dots that we have for
the outcome
these are static in the graph which
means they're independent of the
confounder
similarly we get an independent residual
for the treatment
and now causal inference just becomes a
simple regression of these residuals on
each other
so what we have done really is that
we've used machine learning to
extract out the confounded factors of
both the outcome and the treatment
and once we have those residuals we just
use linear regression or a simple method
to find out the causal effect of t on y
and depending on the data set properties
actually different estimation methods
can be used
so for example we talked about matching
we also talked about
double ml but actually there are many
different methods and you have to try
them
and see based on dataset which one works
the good news is that all these methods
are implemented in dubai
either directly or through a library
from microsoft which is econ ml
and so these all methods which are
pretty complicated
are now available in a simple library
for you to
use with but that's not
enough right so now we have our estimate
that's great
but can you call it a causal estimate
well as you probably remember from the
earlier parts
that m represented causal influence
really depends on the assumptions
right so just having an estimate from a
causal method is not enough
now is our chance to check whether the
assumptions are
actually being valid in in the current
setup
and just as a recap we have assumptions
which are pretty much
untestable for most cases going through
all the three steps that we so far
discussed
so the first step we discussed model
there's an assumption about which edges
should be there or not
maybe we made a mistake there's also an
assumption about whether we missed any
of the observed
variable that could be confounding our
estimate
in identification there can be
assumptions about some parametric
assumption that we made about deriving
the s demand
or some other kind of assumption in the
graph
that we now have to be careful with
whether it actually is valid in the data
or not
and similarly in estimation as you just
saw we made assumptions about the
functional form
we also made some assumptions that might
lead to high variance
in the estimate and so this is quite
important
it's probably to me one of the most
important steps of causal influence
because unlike in machine learning where
you have cross validation
there's no such data set no such gold
test data set available right
so we really have to now get creative
and think of
how can we check the robustness of this
estimate
well the best practice from experts is
that
try to do as many robustness or
refutation tests as possible
so that you can rule out violations of
assumptions
so we have typically two types of tests
you can think from a software
development perspective one is the unit
test
which just tests one part of your
analysis pipeline
so for example you can just test whether
the modeling is correct using a
conditional independence test
similarly you can test identification
using d separation
and so on and separately we have what
you can call
integration tests which just test
whether your whole process is correct or
not right so they just begin with an
assumption about what a correct process
should do
and just test whether your method is
following that
and we'll discuss one or two of these
we'll specifically discuss
the placebo treatment refuter and the
sensitivity analysis
again we won't have time to discuss all
of these methods but they are all
implemented
in dubai the library that we have built
and so you can all
for any kind of estimation now it's very
easy
to just run all these tests at once and
check
these assumptions one caveat i'll say
before we
begin is that these tests are not proofs
they're not able to tell you whether
your analysis is correct or not
think of them more like they can weed
out the bad analysis very quickly right
so they can tell you when a method is
wrong
but they cannot actually it doesn't mean
if all tests pass that the method is
correct
it just means that it's not really bad
and so you've made all the
due diligence in your analysis
okay so i'll describe sort of three
methods just to give an intuition
on how refutation works uh and you can
think of it almost like the scientific
process you have an estimate now
you have a theory and you want to check
and you want to falsify it
so if you have a problem with your
modeling and you're concerned that you
might have missed some
confounding or you might have missed
some other variable
one easy thing we can do is that we use
the knowledge of causal graphs
properties
so we know that every causal graph
implies certain conditional independence
constraints
on its nodes let's take an example so
the graph
on the right you can see that there's a
treatment there's an outcome
but the user has said that there are
other variables a and b
which are affecting the confounder so
just by looking at this graph
we can actually deduce this is
analytically
that a should be independent of b that's
the assertion in the graph
similarly a should be independent of t
the treatment given w
and b should be independent of t given w
as well
now that's pretty nice because the user
has said here are the independences i
believe
exist in my data and the refutation
method can say
sure let me check them i have the data
with me let me just check if these are
correct or not
and that's exactly what this method does
so it says that
let's check if the observed data
satisfies the independence conditions
and for this we implement
an appropriate statistical test if all
the conditional independence is pass
great if not then it means that we have
to look at our model again
and maybe change some arrows or make it
more
complex once you're
not so much worried about your model you
might be worried about
other things down in the steps that
might have gone wrong
right so you might be worried about
maybe there's some problem with the
estimation identification and that's
where integration tests help
so one example is a placebo treatment
all we are saying here
is that we don't know what happened
among the modeling assumptions and the
identification assumptions
but here's something that we can attest
to and which is that if the treatment
is something that is completely random
then it should have no effect on the
outcome right
and that's just a simple assertion and
we can say that
if given such a data set any causal
inference method should return an
estimate of zero and that's exactly what
we do
if you look at the graph on your right
the first one is the true data
and the second one is a simulated data
where we what we do is that we look at
the treatment column
remove it from the data and replace it
with a completely simulated
uniformly random variable so for example
you can choose gaussian
so now because you generated this
variable by yourself you know
that it cannot be uh causing the outcome
and so the effect has to be zero
and then we can just rerun our whole
pipeline check whether with this reduced
treatment uh do we still get the
estimate actually equal to zero
and again if it passes great if it
doesn't uh then the method is incorrect
and we have to
make amends and the final one i'll talk
about
is the most interesting in many ways
which is that we can now test how our
method
would be sensitive to unobserved
confounding
right so remember this is one of the
hardest sort of assumptions in causal
inference
we can never be sure whether in our
modeling there was one
effect or one model sorry one variable
that was missing
and so what we can do is that we can say
sure let's try to simulate a variable
let's try to simulate a confounder with
some correlation
with both treatment and outcome and now
let's redo an analysis again
and see how much our estimate changes
so this method typically doesn't give
you a yes no answer
but it gives you a sense of how robust
you are
to even a small confounder that might
have
gone missing in your data and this can
give you a subjective understanding
of whether the estimate can be trusted
or not
now armed with these four steps
let's just walk through how you can do
them using the do y library
that we talked about it will just give
you a good sense
of how this causal inference analysis
happens in practice
just to make things fun we have actually
created a mystery problem
uh this is available online i'll present
the link later
imagine that you are a data analyst and
someone just gives you a data set and
this is how it looks like
over time x and y seem to be reasonably
correlated
and if you look at the data you have
three variables x y and w
so what do we do so in do y the first
step
is to model the problem first so before
even making thinking about what you're
going to estimate
let's try to model uh this whole setup
here
so that's what you do using the causal
model class as i've shown here
and you specify what variable is the
treatment outcome you can also specify
a graph here and then do i say is great
we have recorded this model and if you
ask it to
present it it can present it as a graph
so here this is sort of a familiar graph
where we have a treatment outcome and
some unobserved confounders
second step now is that given the graph
now everything else is automatic
in dubai the graph is where really human
knowledge and human judgment goes in
after that we just say hey you have the
model let's identify the effect so
that's the second line
of the api and if you see something
interesting is happening
in the outcome that comes from do y
one thing is that it shows you a warning
it tells you that hey this is observed
data
not from a randomized experiment there
might always be some missing confounding
and so this is a way of reminding the
user again
that they have to be careful and recheck
their model in case
something is missing but if not then it
gives you
automatically the exact s demand to
estimate
based on the model given to you right so
it's basically implementing do calculus
for you
so that you can simply give the graph
and you immediately know
what to estimate once you know what to
estimate
now you can say estimate effect so
that's the third part
of our api you save the same model
estimate effect and in this case we're
using linear regression but as i said
you can use sort of multiple methods
of different complexity and so now do y
actually does the estimation and comes
up with the estimate of
one what this means is that changing
the treatment value by one unit would
also change the outcome
by the same one unit what's interesting
is that if you just look here
the causal effect is different from the
observed data it's actually a lower
effect
than what you would have if you just
believed the correlation
and finally the most important step is
to now check whether we
are actually having a robust estimator
or not
here i just show one refuter we chose
the plus placebo treatment refuter
remember the placebo treatment just
replaces the treatment with a placebo
so our goal here is to check whether the
effect now goes to zero or not
as you see in the output the effect does
go to zero not significantly different
and so now we can feel reasonably
confident that our
model is a good one and we can trust the
estimate
in fact because it's a simulated data
set we can also check here
which we can't do in real world and we
actually find that the effect
is the same you can also try out this
whole example on github
it has many more details that you can
check out
at the link below
our goal here was to simply give you a
breeze run through
how do i works and how causal influence
can be made practical
through the four steps in practice
actually do y
is actually much more extensible api
our goal is not just to implement the
four steps but also
allow external implementations for those
four steps
but they still follow the same four step
api
so for example we are now already
supporting estimation methods from
external libraries like econ ml
and cos lml the only difference to a
user would be that instead of saying
backdoor.do y
here they can say backdoor.econml
and we also have external contributions
so for example adam kelleher
we are very thankful to him he's added a
pandas dataflame extension
which means that now you can estimate
causal effects
using the same pandas api as you would
work with a data frame
so in summary we've created an
end-to-end library for causal inference
and you can answer what if questions and
estimate causal effects of any variable
importantly using data and domain
assumptions you need both
and the four steps are repeated again
here i would just repeat the most
important ones which is
we have a formal framework to make
assumptions explicit
and we provide a set of automated tests
to check robustness
of the estimate
let's pause for a second and think of
what we've achieved so far
we started with a problem that machine
learning is
five is powered by correlations uh and
then we discovered that causal influence
is a great framework
that can help us make sense of the data
and find out the causal effects of any
variable we're interested in
and so that's where we are but actually
in the last five or six years
there's been another set of work going
on that's even more interesting in some
sense
so what's happening is that we are
realizing that we can use causal
inference to
also improve machine learning right so
it's not just that machine learning
methods can be used
for high dimensional causal inference
actually causal inference can be used
for machine learning and that's really
exciting
so what i'll talk about is just give a
view into
this recent research a lot of it is
active and we'll see
how causal models can be more
generalizable
they can have better privacy guarantees
and they
also give you a very principled
framework for thinking about responsible
machine learning all right
let's get into it so what is causal
learning
so if you're familiar with standard
machine learning
we are typically given a data set and
our goal is to predict y
as a function of x and what we do is
that even though
you might have some information
sometimes for example on the right
i'm showing you a graph people don't use
that and they just say that
just minimize the loss of a function of
x to y
causal learning says that that's not
enough to truly build
generalizable models let's use the
knowledge that we have
about our variables so in this case we
say that the graph shows us that
only xc are the set of variables that
are causing y
because they are the parents in the
graph all the others are simply
correlated or blocked by xc
so what causal learning says is that
let's just build a model
only on the xc variables in most cases
actually
we have to learn the representation of
xc it's not like xc is given to us
and so therefore causal ml problem
becomes the problem of learning a causal
feature
representation as i'll show it has it
can have lower train accuracy
at some points but it does stay
consistent with new domains
and so these are the three benefits that
you get if you can build a model that
only depends on the causes
the first benefit is that the out of
distribution error of causal models
is lower in the worst case the intuition
is simple if you have a
graph like this imagine that you move to
a different domain
right so you may have an intervention
that means that the distribution
of data might change the distribution of
features might change and that's what is
being shown by the hammers here
but the best part about causal features
is that
across all these interventions the
function that connects the causal
features to the outcome
stays the same and so if you have a
model that sort of is predicting disease
in one hospital
it's going to be the same as you move it
to other hospitals as well
the second property that we get is that
it also has stronger differential
privacy guarantees
than associational models this is
a slightly technical result but just to
give the intuition
a causal model because it's focusing on
the common
invariant relationships it doesn't
really care about the
individual specific relationships right
so the extent to which you can use the
predictions from a causal model
to identify back some individuals in the
data
has to be low and and what we show is
that in practice
the differential privacy guarantee can
is always stronger
for a causal model compared to a machine
learning model
and finally just because of differential
privacy benefits
we are also able to show that causal
models are more robust to privacy
attacks
like membership inference so in
membership inference what happens is
just by knowing the output of a machine
learning model
just by knowing the logits for example
you can predict
whether a particular person was in the
training data of a machine learning
model or not
and just sort of very intuitively this
happens because
sometimes machine learning models
overfit to the data and so their
predictions
hold information about the training set
and since we are better in causal
modeling with differential privacy
it turns out models are also more robust
to privacy attacks
now how to build causal predictive
models is
a really exciting area of research and
this is something that
our group at microsoft also works in
there are
three main ways that have come up one is
use multiple domains
and the diversity in those domains the
other is to use some randomized
experiment data
and the final one is to use causal
constraints so domain knowledge
that people would have and we are very
excited to see what more comes up in the
future
for building these models that also
generalize well
and just finally i want to end with this
showing that causal reasoning
also provides useful definitions of
responsible ai concepts like explanation
and fairness
so imagine that the typical example of
explanation is that
you applied for a loan but you were
denied what happens typically is that
you may have a future important
explanation saying that
annual income was the most important but
this gives no information to you it
doesn't tell you what you can do
and that's where causality comes in uh
there's been work proposing counter
factual explanations which says
explicit knowledge about if you change
your income to ten hundred thousand you
would have got the loan
right so it's really sort of telling you
what you can change
and giving you actionable information
that can be useful
and similarly fairness also can be
explored from a causal angle
the simple idea is that if you can find
counter counterfactual explanations for
a model
using only sensitive attributes like
gender most likely
there's a problem with the classifier
and there's a formal definition of it
in kushner at all and i give you a
simple example that if you find
a person gets rejected while just
changing the gender
that's a problem with the model and you
can extend it using more formal
counter factual definitions
so in summary causal reasoning can help
us enable better generalization
better privacy and more responsible ml
models
so there's a lot of interesting work
still to be done in this area
just to conclude we hope that during
this session we were able to communicate
that causal inference is key to many
decision making tasks
we can capture what if scenarios that
are not captured by traditional ml
but more importantly it's also harder
right so there's no free lunch we have
to model assumptions well
and we also have to be careful to
validate them
more excitingly i think there's
interesting exchange between
conventional ml and causal ml like we
just talked about
and this is a very exciting area that we
are contributing to as well
we also want to make these resources
more available
and more accessible to a broader
computer science community
so that's why we are starting to write a
book we've written a few chapters
on causal machine learning that is
publicly available on the link here
and of course we also have our dubai
library that we would love if you can
check out
and also if you're interested in our
publications you can check out the
publications
of our causal ml group at this link
below with that uh i thank you
uh it's been a great pleasure uh giving
this webinar
and now we look forward to your
questions so embryo and i will now be
live
and we'll be taking questions
hi everyone thanks for attending the
foundations of causal infants and its
impacts on machine learning webinar we
are now
in the live q a session i'm amit sharma
and i have with me emre kachaman and
over the next 15 minutes we are going to
be answering
some of the questions that you asked us
through the chat
let's get started so our first question
that
we are asking is what do you do when you
don't have
the causal model and how do you actually
go ahead
and start constructing a causal model
for a practical system
emre you want to answer that
now let's max the research using causal
inference that's really fun
are we live yet
we are live it sounds like emery's
having some connection
issues i mean if you want to take that
one you can go ahead
sure uh so uh
one of the things to understand is that
we don't need the full
we don't need the full causal graph uh
we just need certain variables that we
are interested in so let's suppose your
goal is to estimate
uh the effect of a recommendation system
where you know that there is one product
that's being like
shown and the other product that's
recommended next to it so in that case
it's not important to know
all that is happening in the
recommendation system
or the live system all we need to say
is that here is a product here is a
second product
and one of the biggest features that's
probably impacting both of them
are users preferences for these two
products
right so as long as you have variables
that
speak to the user's preferences and you
have other variables which are
contextual variables like time
location and so on you're already in a
good place with respect to causal
analysis
in the sense that if you assume this
causal model
that these variables are the confounders
for you then what you estimate will
already be better than what you could
have estimated
by just sort of putting all the
variables together in a model so that's
perhaps the first
insight but we don't really need to
model the full system i think all you
need to do is for a specific question
you just want to find the variables uh
that are relevant
to that question and all the others can
be put up as one sort of
unobserved nodes or confounders
the second thing to note is that
i am ray
do you want to take on answer this
question
oh it seems like uh emre is having some
trouble uh the last thing i would add
about
causal models is that it's often
a dialogue in our experience with the
domain experts
whenever we start with a problem i think
as computer scientists we often have
this
desire to learn as much as possible from
the data
but one of the fundamental results in
causal
discovery is that it's
not possible to uniquely determine a
graph
based on just observational data so you
either need to do a lot of experiments
or what we found in practice that's very
useful is that we talk to the domain
experts
if you're let's say looking at a system
that is in healthcare we can talk to
doctors
if similarly for any other system we can
talk to the people who designed it or
who know more about it
and i think the key insight that we want
to convey today
is that it's just about
having the right causal model even if
it's an incomplete causal model
in practice what you'll observe is that
even with that incomplete causal model
you'll be
closer to the true estimate uh compared
to not using it
so that's another way to think about
this problem is that even with
a partial model that's causal you may
get better insights
than having no model at all
let's look at the second question
that came up so this was about
explanation actually two of you asked
this question
so there are explanation methods like
shapley values
there are also other future importance
methods
and the question is how does
causal inference and do y differ from
these methods and also how can do y be
used
for future importance
so the first thing is to understand that
many of these feature importance methods
if you
think about them and just abstract into
what they're doing they essentially say
that given this input this set of let's
say x1 x2 x3 features
there was a particular output y-hat that
i observed
these methods say let's try to imagine
multiple scenarios
or now that we have this vocabulary
multiple counterfactual words
where these features took on some other
value and then they try to
estimate on all these words what was the
importance of a particular feature
right so this is what methods like
shapley value do they say that
let's imagine words where x1 was
initially one
and then we see how much effect you get
when you add x2 as well
and similarly you can say x2 was 1 and
how much effect does x1 at right
and so there are many such methods but
the sort of key
challenge they have is that they have no
knowledge of
what ordering is the right ordering and
which
combinations of variables are just
impossible in the world
and i think that is what do y offers
here is that if you're trying to do
future importance if you're trying to do
explanation
in any of these methods you can imagine
having
a causal graph behind it that tells you
whether certain combinations are
possible
not not possible at all so by domain
knowledge you would know that two
features can never be won
at the same time or maybe you also know
that it's always that
x1 is the first feature that is
activated
so the short answer is that i think
there's interesting ways in which causal
influence can be used
for explainability but i think one of
the first ways is
even just understanding that it helps us
construct these set of counter factual
words
against which you are explaining
something
how it happens in practice we have a
couple of notebooks on dubai on github
essentially you can think of trying to
estimate the causal effect of each
feature one by one
on the outcome while you're conditioning
for
the other set of features that you have
then there was a another question about
how microsoft research is using causal
influence
so here this has been an interesting
journey for us
where we found causal inference
applications
in a number of places at microsoft
uh so i'll talk about some of the sort
of things that we started working in and
now
i think the various places in which
causal instance is having an impact
uh so where we started was
uh questions about online networks
uh online recommendation systems uh
emerald did
some great work on online social
networks
uh hi ambry are you are you back
yes i am sorry about those technical
difficulties
um not sure exactly do you want to take
this
yeah so we were just discussing this
question about how microsoft research
is using causal influence and i started
the answer by saying that
we both of us started with online
systems i think you did some work
with social networks i was working on
recommendation systems
but i think now we are seeing that there
are multiple applications in business
and marketing for example
uh sales as well in uh finding out the
right
interventions we are also seeing
applications
in traditional machine learning sort of
predictive models and how you can make
them
more generalizable to new domains uh
and then off also their applications in
sort of finding out for whom the
intervention
works well so there are applications
in uh bing as well and some others maybe
embryo you want to
talk more about how we're using it
yes i mean the way i see the place where
causal inference can have the most
direct impact on our computing systems
and the way i abstract it out
is is really around decision making
systems that
the places where we're making decisions
and intervening in the system as a
result of
of a machine learning model is
where we need causal methods the most
and this
this this thinking i think really spans
a lot of of domains
we've certainly seen it in trying to
understand
the signals that we get from people's
you know digital traces
to help us understand what's happening
in the real world in uh
health contexts um you know with
real world evidence we see it in online
systems
where we're studying user behavior to
understand what's working and not
working
in our products
and we're even starting to see it in you
know industrial context
as well where people are using machine
learning models in more
in a variety of industry agriculture and
other settings
as well as the sales and marketing type
of
domains that you where econometrics is
has more conventionally used
use these methods
i guess one other interesting kind of
test where we're doing this type of work
now amit is also in
trying to trying to use
causal insights to improve uh
traditional
machine learning tasks as well so how do
we improve
prediction and classification for
example where we
might not you know need necessarily
a causal understanding of the underlying
system but where we believe
that by using causal methods or relying
on more causal features and
relationships we'll be able to improve
really core machine learning
attributes that we care about like
generalizability and robustness
yeah that's that's a great point emre
and it actually connects well to a
question that was also asked
uh which was that uh how can we
understand why conventional ml methods
may not work as well and what is the
secret sauce behind
causal methods that make them generalize
well
so i'll just give a very simple example
here that can
vet our intuitions here so this is a
common problem that has now
been well researched and it's an active
area
of research as well which which is
assuming that you have two
domains and you're trying to make a
prediction task so you can even imagine
the simplest task
in computer vision which is mnist and
you're trying to predict
the digit uh based on the image you see
and it can just happen that in these two
domains in one of the domains uh
color is correlated with the digit
and when you just do conventional ml it
just tries to look for the simplest
feature
or the most sort of easy way to get to
the right prediction and a high
accuracy and so in conventional level
models they have no way to know whether
color is the right feature or whether
the shape
is the right feature and i think what we
are seeing is that
infusing some of the techniques and
insights from causal inference
into the prediction problem so for
example in this case you can develop
causal regularizers to to say that some
features like shape are more important
here
what it does is that it then gives you
your your predictive model as well
more generalizability to new domains
so that's just one of the simplest
examples where you can think of like
when you have data from multiple domains
how do you extract the features that
they
consistent over all these domains
i think one thing that's worth
emphasizing
is that when the traditional ml models
are relying
solely on the data and so if you have
superior correlations
in your data your model won't be able to
you know easily distinguish between the
spurious and the and the causal
relationships and when we know the
experience once
by definition they might change because
of some environmental
difference and what causal methods let
us do is it formalizes
it helps us formalize our assumptions
about
either the structure of the data
gathering process or about the fact that
data came from multiple environments and
it helps us bring
that knowledge into the analysis
um in a more systematic and rigorous way
and and that's that provides that extra
little bit of
um nugget to help us
focus these models on on the causal
relationships
where it otherwise i wouldn't say that
there's anything
that we're able to do with data alone
with the causal method that we couldn't
do with the conventional machine
learning model
it's the fact that the causal analysis
is bringing in an ability to
reason about some additional structural
or relationships
between among the data itself
yeah so maybe we have
time for one last question
uh i think there's a question about uh
unobserved confounding
we obviously talked a lot about that in
the presentation and the question is how
do we account for
unobserved confounders in our causal
model
so uh maybe i can start so
uh there are two places in which uh
we want to account for them uh so the
first place
that is in the modeling itself uh often
what happens is
if you're doing the traditional
statistical analysis or even the
machine learning analysis what happens
is you look at what data is available to
you as emory was saying
and you try to build the best estimator
for your
effect or for your quantity that you're
interested in
the downside of this is that if your
data itself
is does not have all the right variables
or it misses some
really important variable your estimate
might be off
and you would have no formal way or even
no intuitive way of knowing that that is
happening
so i think the first way unobserved
confounders can be used and this is
what we have tried to do in do i is that
you explicitly tell
or state that in your causal model
itself
so in your graph for example you can say
not only that there is an unobserved
confounder i believe
that is affecting this problem but also
how is it affecting this problem right
so is it just
as causing one of the variables in your
model or is it causing probably all the
variables in your model or some middle
ground
so i think that's one way that we
account for it and this is this just
gives us a perspective or some humility
into what the estimate that we are
capturing is really capturing so is it
the causal effect or not right so that's
number one
i think the second way that we can
account for it and this is
also one of the probably the biggest
strengths of do y
as a library is that you can do your
analysis without having access to that
variable
but at the last step in the refutation
you can say that
i know my analysis is not perfect
because there was an unobserved
confounder
let me try to now simulate such a
and try to see how much my estimate
changes
so this is you can think of like a
sensitivity analysis
where what we are saying is that we
don't know how big that confounding was
but we can simulate confounders of
different strengths
which are unobserved and see how much
our estimate would have changed if we
did include such a variable
in our analysis and looking at that
uh along with sort of domain knowledge
of how strong a confounder could be
that's missing
i think that can give us a much better
idea of how robust our estimators
and also how trustable or generalizable
it may be
yeah yeah just following up on that it
it turns out that even when we don't
have the opportunity to observe
uh these conf a particular confounder
the domain experts can still have
intuition about how strong
that relationship might be and if we are
able to compare the strength of
the unobserved confounding that's
necessary to
[Music]
reverse our our understanding of a
causal relationship
what um
what we see that we can take a look at
that strength and compare to the
strength of the confounders that we are
able to see and then a domain expert can
say yeah it's not
it's not doesn't make sense that there's
someone observed control that's
thousands or millions of times stronger
than anything that we've seen so far
and maybe in that case you trust your
analysis more than if even a tiny bit of
confounding
uh were to um were to
reverse your your estimates
great uh thank you all for attending
today uh
we really appreciate your participation
and all the questions that you asked
if you're interested in learning more we
have some great resources
in the resource list to the right of
your screen
the list includes references to the duvy
library on github
and within that on that library you
would find
notebooks there that you can explore as
case studies
on how do y can be used uh and also
there are links to
book chapters that we are writing on the
same topic of
causality and machine learning and you
can find the first two chapters of our
book
also available in the resources we look
forward to seeing how you can build on
this research
and evolve the area of causality and
machine learning
for any further questions i would say
we are happy you can probably reach out
to us you can find us
online and also on the dubai issues page
you can raise issues you can raise
questions and we'll be happy to answer
them with that have a great day
and thank you so much thanks everyone